oh yeah hey hey oh there's the camera
it's over here
hey hey hey I think I am live to eat
chat starts moving I did have it like
mess up on me one time what I did is
stream from stream up nuts up up up so I
am live I think I am somewhat delayed so
hey there we go there's people now I see
them hey guys - oh shut up
shut up dude you don't get to talk so
hey guys welcome to the Tatia launch
stream my graphic novel Tanya it's
unbelievably exciting to be able to show
this book to everyone to unleash it upon
the world and so far we've had a great
response
so Tavia
is currently right now the number one
creative project creative works on amiga
it's number one you can start to number
one on IndieGoGo Creek works already
it's been like four hours it's been four
hours so a number five it's just in
general so that includes all like that
yes like tech products in coffee
machines there's a coffee machine on
life is crowdfunding that's right but
yeah so yeah we don't we're number one
in creative works number five so it is
growing here we are going up so if you
have not checked out the campaign page
make sure you check it out if you we're
on the mailing list like 2015 15 to 20%
off you get like 20% off like a signed
paperback version get 50% off like a
sign hardcover if you were on the
mailing list
but yeah so basically I don't know how
clear this is for you guys but basically
digital copy $10 because we want it like
a very low price point or the digital
copy so anybody can just read it
basically we don't want it to be like
super Simpson and the same with the
paperback paperback is only $15 from
impact not science so it was very very
very very very important for me to like
have a low price point for these like
entry levels learn to read the book I
just wanted people read it I don't have
any marking up the price and selling a
really expensive book for no reason so
what everybody really read it and I want
to unleash the story to the world
so you 10 bucks 10 bucks and then you
can also get like an audio script
version narrated by yours truly that's a
long answer so yeah it is pretty freakin
amazing that we are so high up on
already and yeah so the also the trailer
just launched on my channel if you
haven't seen that you can check that out
I put on my bed I put on my best
spooky voice describing Tatia story so
Tonia you don't know what it's all about
they probably have been taken because
I've been talking about it a lot but
it's a Pattaya is my graphic novel on
witches and mythology a lot of other
things so basically what I wanted to do
was I wanted to tell um very insane
story about a character but then Creed's
like a fantasy backdrop in order and to
invent this fantasy backdrop what I did
was I took me at all you smaller on the
world
I took Celtic mythology of surrounding
Bale or in his evil eye and the flooring
twisted it invented I took the god
the contact with student intern a little
bit I took mythology from my Africa
Norse mythology bits and pieces from all
over the place and uses all of this and
changed it enough and formed the fantasy
backdrop of the story so far
Wow Talia has very recognizable elements
recognizable fancy elements like the
Dark Lord
Baylor that's rising and the opposite to
him which is Hakata so creation versus
consumption and all that going on in the
background while the story itself is
about the character Tanya and her being
in the middle of this covenant witches
so yeah I didn't want to just I did what
I definitely didn't want to do this book
was tell like be save the world be the
hero and defeat the Dark Lord story that
is not the story you like I said it's in
the backdrop but what it is what it is
what the story is about and it's heart
it is a this character Tanya and her
realizing her potential realizing what
she is what she's capable of and
realizing that she's been manipulated so
you have a becoming daughters of our
common witches that inhabit morass and
they've been habited morale for hey what
is up great very in the chat hey agree
oh yeah so the daughters of the cocktail
have inhabited wrath for centuries and
I'm not gonna give away too much about
their backstory initially because I want
you guys to figure it out on your own
but basically what they have been doing
was if you needed to if you needed
anything and you were desperate enough
you could stumble into the forest and
maybe stumble stumbled upon the black
altar and make an offering to the
witches of the woods
the daughters the [ __ ] a and they would
grace they would offer you well a
position they would save a loved one
that was dying for magic but because
they gave you this gift at some point
they would
require a boom they require payment and
it was or the it is a bond that sealed
in blood right so it is a generational
bond so let's say your grandfather made
a pact these witches several several
decades pass or grandfather is dead but
you know you inhabit the sins of your
ancestors that's what's basically going
on here
so and then if you don't want to pay
them back if you don't rent them boom
yes then they destroy you and so there's
this deeper dilemma that's going on with
the witches versus the current king and
I will not get too much into that just
yet but let's let's let's move on let's
not get too much into story about that
but just keep that in mind just keep
that in mind
you're right Carl Carl are witches ain't
cheap they're not cheap great they're
not cheap um so basically the character
time we're talking comes into play I'm
keep in mind of this this coven of
witches in particular the leader of the
coven mother Silas has a vendetta
against Gideon for multiple reasons one
of the reasons is of course he did and
then there's also another reason that
comes to the plate later here so the
creation of Tanya was basically to
destroy me and also let me explain why
it is also why on top of the vendetta
what I have to go back to explain why
the witch is known to be in the first
place so when the witches require a
payment it's always something there it's
never gonna be like give me like a
hundred gold pieces unless they just
need a basis for some reason it's gonna
be something that they need so something
about morass and what's happening now
for the majority of the history of
morass the pagan ways were honored
essentially so making offerings to the
gods of the trees the florists got to
look at wathah
all of that
what that did was in the beliefs of the
worshipers was basically it allowed
little off the to guard the barrier
between the context realm and barrier in
famous realm which was outside the
context realm but recently like with him
that last 100 years or so 200 years or
so the divinity has begun to rise and
basically the divinity is and to my
analog for medieval Christianity
essentially but with some differences
and the divinity basically shut out any
type of worship of any other they have
one God the Father and worship of the
chihuaha is not permitted worship of
anything that is not the father is not
permitted and so the widgets go to
Gideon after they see that the barrier
has been fading the to lhasa guard the
barrier are not being fed by the people
of Maratha and so they've grown weak and
they can no longer properly guard the
barrier against Phelan that's amore and
they are pressing on the borders of the
Empire
let's see they're pressing on the
borders of the and so the which is so he
can get and they say and you please
kinda like pull back on this on the
divinity check for the divinity a little
bit make it so that they don't persecute
worshippers of the old ways so much just
make it a little bit easier make it so
that witchcraft isn't so persecuted in
morale we have a boom you owe us this
give it to us and he refuses but you
might say Quinn how could he refuse you
say it's full-on pact they can't just
refuse a Blood Pact when he's bound by
blood oh well like I said there is a
normal man and then there is a king a
king has been raised up bow before race
to above all the penance that you are a
leader you are keepers
there is innate esoteric power in fact
entirely in the same way all of us that
there is like innate esoteric power
Kings blood in George
my song I see fire in the same way in
plane but almost that deep so a normal
man that denied them their moon they
could easily destroy they could easily
bring his castle down upon him he looks
but a king no no you can't simply take
down the king you need me to be the
greater plan maybe the more significant
had a longer plan it's something that's
worth meticulous and waited to planned
out and so that is where the creation of
Tatia comes in
Tatia who the witches have created to
ultimately be the undoing okay and so
that is the base story of the entire
series so this is gonna be told in three
books this is the first book that we're
doing to campaign right here for
campaign for the first book and the
first of all is the first part of the
story we follow
we see the creation of Todd that we see
Todd his birth we see Tonya as a
teenager living in the town father's
castle Timothy and we see her slowly
start to uncover that things are
changing a little bit people are
changing people are going missing there
have been murders so there's very
strange happenings as the l'amore press
on the course of the Empire and also the
workings of witches and her and Todd he
is a name yes are also starting to waken
at this point time and so that's what
this first vlog is about it's almost
Aria and I created a baby I think that's
what's quite spooky first boy it's quite
it's quite the spooky story got some
nice twist in there um someone asked me
the other day was toddy a Mary Sue and I
read the script again today right before
we launched her this morning just
because nerves so three makes my spirit
and she's not she's not she really isn't
I definitely tried really hard to give
her a lot of struggles to make sure
things don't always go away to make sure
things aren't always easy for her
because I wanted the character to evolve
and grow
so she starts off kind of innocent kind
of night but you can tell there's like
some some wit and some intelligence
behind her and you see that grow not
only over the core so these three
volumes that relieves but over the
course of this first look as well so
let's talk about other characters so we
mentioned the King Gideon Gideon is the
current king the breadth of Iraq and
Gideon has five children we won't even
but it is only mention Gideon has
mentioned several times but he doesn't
appear and so one thing about Gideon he
employs the ash makers so the ash makers
are sent out by the divinity and
employed but they provide King and so
the ash makers are basically there to
start out any of the old ways any worse
but they don't wait anything witchcraft
I'm leading offerings to the to Lhasa
any of that they stamp it out is
absolutely not accepted if the ash
makers did call thing we gotta have a
bad time and see here's the thing too
with witches if you're real wait you're
not really gonna get caught by the ash
makers most likely so basically what
they're doing one is they're weakening
the barrier by making people to offer to
the trumpet and two they're just like
kind of persecuting people and calling
them which is when they're not so that
kind of in a lot of ways witch trials
and such the ash makers come into play
more they show right at the end so okay
[Music]
let's talk about all deus toddies
grandfather
so all these is introduced right at the
beginning so using your skill all of
these made a pact with and and if you go
if you go watch the early art reveal
your building the layouts we actually
people I kind of narrate to see a little
bit so Todd here years ago
Tiny's grandfather
basically a peasant hanging to the
riches of the Black Forest and made an
offering if they accept it
and he wrote he rose and became a large
rose to power until he's wealthy and so
they come to him
many years later requiring a movement
saying give us you have first of all one
dot would become Tommy's mother so yeah
so that's that's where all these comes
into play that's how that all worked and
there's Timothy who's Talia's father and
then we've also got any ideas stepmom
we've gathered who's a total you know I
have stepmom and something insane so I
was able to write pretty good I was able
to capture that stepmom essence really
doesn't like the kid but tolerates the
kid yeah I mean well really yes I was
taught his younger sister and actually
she has a much more significant role in
the same and then there's also Damian
who's Tanya's very young he's only just
four five so that's that's Todd his
family
let's see so we talked about mother
Silas who is the leader of the coven
the dodge of the containg she is the
only member of she's one of the only
members of the coven that is actually
but yeah you need to know if she is
she's a very she definitely is in every
age she's moving all the pieces she's
basically the chess master mother Silas
and then we've got it Sam who comes into
play at some point in this novel second
time is toddies hand me a very very very
interesting
character variants Alisha since I was
hoping came out PayPal was it I don't
work that's something I can even turn on
but I will look into that for you to see
it that is actually if that will figure
something out definitely Paul's been
waiting for this day order to sign copy
with digital audio thank you so much
thanks everyone that has back to tie
your so far like the last time I checked
we rose to number one on IndieGoGo
creative works like 30 minutes we rose
to number so we're you know absolutely
this killing the page here see what we
got now so we had last time I checked we
totally smashed our first flexible go
which is totally awesome thank you so
much very great also if you wanna like
hop on and chat I'm not sure how my
internet is the way to work but if you
do wanna hop on totally it's like I
would do that right now
see if grey area wants to get on stream
and just like chat hang out make it a
streaming party if you don't it's cool
but I will send the cheap just two days
invite copy I'm sending it to you on
Twitter to clean it up there you go
so yeah all right back to the stream so
like I said thanks everyone so much
crossed by 44 backers only then it's
only then like four hours very important
for us to pound these entry-level price
works like a digital copy for $10 and
paperback 15 once I was the book to the
I know people charge link 25:34 just
like a paperback that's not signed but
I'm doing I know what the printing costs
are it doesn't hurt me that much to give
you guys like a price point I really
want everyone to just read it and like
see all three covers by the
reburying covers and Matthew Walden's
completed layer today and I saw Matthew
Logan's cover is actually going to have
like a whole back cover which we um when
it's done well covered it's going to
have a full back so if you want if you
want a really interesting look at the
world and also there's that beautiful
and of course the cover of Duncan a
Georgia same you did all the duck neck
books covers for the Song of Ice and
Fire
comic books my cover and then we also
got it so good like I said yeah so you
got three different colors that you can
choose from and also cover for 15 and
then that comes with digital copy signed
mental creams
digital audio scripts and then and then
the book which is the most extensive
turn there's only like ten of these
digital copy number sign high cover
metal print digital atmospheres original
art page and then B Java so yeah all the
least expensive most expensiv
for this
simply like a price point for everybody
something that I was like dead set on
from the beginning I would not be
dissuaded for that double price point
but yeah it is so exciting absolutely so
exciting to be showing this book to the
world and it's so exciting
- when - great did you say he wanted to
come on I didn't know if she said oh
okay
well thanks very thanks for being here
to support me but yeah thanks thanks
thanks for being here in the chat and I
need to make your moderator I'll have to
do that later because I can't do it from
the street
let's make great area oh she's already
acknowledged it so that's Martin sweet
oh that's a great question kukuku says
why did you choose breath novel instead
of a novel alright I've gotten this
question a couple times actually so the
reason is well basically because they
come in I came into contact with links
and people in the comic industry but
also because recently what like within
the last four or five years I've been
reading a lot graphic novels like Alan
Moore Neil Gaiman just anything Brian
Kavon just reading every anything my
hands on Joe Hill's like lucky is really
good you know it's there's something
about opening up a page opening a book
and just seeing the art and just like
seeing it straight up and not having to
like read the description it's a
different it's a totally different thing
I mean I've always loved reading a novel
and just reading boards because love
times not always a lot of times enough
with a lot more descriptive but not
always there's a lot that can be
conveyed through art that is actually
better than once
and so in my new novel about Atlantis
that's what this is my string now so
we're early so ever yeah so yeah but
there's so there's something about the
medium opening a page seeing the day
large and that is reading dialog it just
you absorb it and I also like to read
novels that a bit and vice versa I know
that Sandman is being adapted into an
audiobook and then there's also like
Neil Gaiman he wrote this book called
raising which I love about this little
boy that was like raised at a great guy
he was like given freedom of the
graveyard by all these ghosts and that
was adapted into graphic novel and in
the graphic novel just add something
more to it they just add something else
so one thing we are one thing it is I'm
going to after these three books are
finish we do this campaign next campaign
finally we're gonna release it again as
a novel and then we're also gonna have
like the bow hardcover of all like the
big omnibus but we're also gonna release
it someone said the sound quality is so
bad my ears are bleeding well I don't
like I can't even look see here's the
thing you see no internet right now
she's worried with me trying to campaign
I think it's actually doing pretty I
mean I can't hear the audio but I can
see it's not great not terrible let me
get a little bit closer actually it's
Edith that does help a little bit
I don't I get too close to the screen
I'll create you guys alright let's see
so so like I said if you haven't seen
the trailer to the trailer is on my
channel it's also
front of beef it's also on the front of
the Doug Brower says that dick the
welding cover but struggled with
deciding it's a great choice any of
these covers are great choice but like I
said that welding cover as I can awesome
wrap around back cover that will be
revealed later today ones while it's
finished
well has a perfectionist so I'm finish
all those pieces but the version of
welding that's up there right now is
actually just like that layout you guys
have any seen the fetched I've seen the
sneak peek of the finished it's not even
done and it just looks so imagine what's
out there but just like infinitely
better in every way and also with like
an awesome wraparound covered with like
a bunch of characters on the back like
it's got quality songs that can stuff
mother Silas in the back yeah it's
really really cool
yeah well that is the main now you know
another thing about welding just as a
person great person so unbelievably
passionate about his work and about this
project when he started sending me just
the layouts for his vision for Tatia
after he read the script I was like I
which I was right because he just has
such an incredible vision and incredible
eye and just like he just puts so much
passion into like every line draws and
it beautifully shows but I could not be
happier with wellnitz work I could not
be happier with his work on Tanya
and like I said this is a Weldon Howard
project right this this is a 50/50 split
I made sure but I went to Matthew Alden
and said I want you to have 50% of this
project because like to me the art is
just as important as the words when it
comes to graphic novel like I'm always
going on and on and on about Sandman
overtures because it's like the art in
the original Sandman is great but the
Shh Williams comes in to do Sam an overt
and JH Williams's Lake these graders
coming back artists in the business
pretty much like James Williams is like
the best and so that combination of a
beautiful art and just a beautiful story
it just it just takes it to an entirely
and Weldon doing the the art have been
Sean Francois Jean Francois bolt you're
doing the colors Jean Francois polios
colors are just absolutely breathtaking
and if you don't know about John
Francois he did Middle West for image
comic recently ah so that's really
really cool so that's that's why that's
how actually we took notice of him I
actually have minutes and I really
really do have it I swear to you I
promise you I had it but my stupid
friend grit me you talking you Britney
took my copy of Middle West and now I
can't show it up to the people and now I
look like a poser but yeah I actually do
I had a copy of his Middle West before
like but of the Middle West that he
colored before like we even got him to
do Tatia so I was already a fan and then
we got him to do it I was like yeah yeah
so if there's so thanks great airier for
posting the link again to the todd sword
let's talk about that name you guys
figured that name out yeah anybody
Toddie exordium we know that means what
let's see let's see if you guys can
figure it out before I flirted deal it
pretty simple pretty simple if you know
just what coordinates hundred fifty five
backers baby
right now so someone just post some chat
just excellent guys honestly I want to
say this like I had to do so yeah I just
want to say guys I had like no
expectations really for this I hope that
Lake I wished I was saying like it's
like 50 books be great if I could sell
like just like enough to just like have
it be worth printing then I would be
satisfied I'd be happy early I'd be
happy that I was out that people were
actually reading it and interesting but
you guys kind of blew my mind it's
honestly like it's a number one on
IndieGoGo creative works and let me
check again to see exactly where we are
as far as like the general and campaigns
so now that's a good thing my internet
speaks let's see all categories Tatia is
number two
taani is number two it's on the front
page oh my god oh my goodness guys she's
sitting on the front page looking
beautiful well - I'm blown away
yeah alright I had already beat up
people it was like yes yes it's number
one let's get it to number one guys
we're on the front page so let's do this
let's do this
so I don't know what in the house amigo
goes algorithm works with that getting
it on the front page what not but yeah
guys are really really it's super sick
like I said guys this support is
breathtaking
absolutely breathtaking I'm just pulling
up any about.com this Amazon tablet and
also like the really great for reading
comics are also the great for reading
comics on now get it so they're tiny is
yeah confirm G's on the front page which
is it things which is awesome I mean
even if you guys even if you like can't
support I'm here right now I know times
are I totally understand share Tatia all
over the place share it bug your friends
on Facebook felt a yet posted all over
Twitter yet
twitter twitter you post it all over
Twitter posted all over Instagram posted
everywhere you can cuz we the most
important thing is we get the word out
so we can get as much funding for this
possible because if we can we can get
stretch goals we can add more splash
pages to the book and do all sorts of
interesting things that get like we can
we can we could we can just make it
better and then the the cool thing about
stretch goals is that if we can get to
the stretch goals the people that are
the the book does not go in price go up
in price so the book just gets better
and it's still the same price so the
more people the better book becomes and
it still stays same price it will still
be $15 it'll still be $10 for the e-book
it'll still be $50 for the hard copy so
yeah P money says got my copy thank you
so much thanks everyone
things everyone that side of the mailing
list thing someone that's had a kind
words saying thanks everyone that's been
sharing it
hashtag we do post it everywhere
posted yes right through them
and also thank you very little for being
here actually right do you know what you
deserve you deserve this the main is for
a while there you go buddy there you go
Lauren what is up how's it going I'm
excited to see all my friends here
that's so that's what's that's what's
great um and also great I just want to
say I can't make great area know with
how supportive she has been with Tatia
play three totally got the blow up she
backed it and she's just been really
supportive sharing it between me so just
thank you so much great then I wait to
see you again in person correct through
the sense unlimited power
well right here like that every stream
basically and you're a member and you've
been here for like more than a here at
this point so it's safe you get a rich
you get orange you'll get a raise so
yeah what else can we say about Tonya
but talk about the cane in a white cover
so we were showing you you never see you
look at this came back on Twitter and on
the community page
thanks so much vici 3100 eight for your
super shaft thanks thanks a lot for that
looks great and thanks ray Kaitlyn's
educated why exist chilled it was
covered in white is one of the best
artists in coming industry period my
opinion I don't care anything absolutely
well besides the Olbermann observance
you
guess who's back back again
it's me quit my phone that I was
streaming off of and casting my hot spot
from died but now it is back because
stream yard is awesome and it doesn't
shut down the stream wait he went
something like that happened so yeah we
are back guys how's it going what did I
miss that I missed something important I
missed something big
all right so we're back over they talk
about yeah we were dumb out let me know
my sound and looking good everybody
sound good
look good I can't see the chat let me
refresh it and actually move it over
here doesn't move and that one live
comments okay there we go now it's see
alright so yeah we got the kny comedy
super awesome
we also got the Mike Miller cover which
I don't had like pulled up here but you
can go look at the Mike Miller cover you
can actually look at him draw it on his
channel black list universe because he
finished it up last night it's basically
like Tydeus face super close-up and it's
stunning it's absolutely stunning um so
yeah that's Mike Miller's covered and
then there is of course the Matthew
Weldon cover which I'm really excited
about Matthew Alden cover I'm excited
about all of them but really excited
about the Matthew Alden one because the
Matthew Alden one has a wraparound cover
that has a bunch of characters on it and
it's super awesome
someone says someone gave a super chair
anime lover and says enemy lover Nicole
says what does Tatia mean what is the
name Todd yeah um thank you for your
super chat but I'm so sorry because that
is for you guys think that you're out I
can't I cannot reveal that information I
am not at liberty to discuss it but know
that Tatia does in fact mean something
we should do something yes it is a
reveal which I've already told you guys
to like the on look out for like
meetings in names in all the name
IIIi love doing that stuff I love
putting hittin meetings all over the
place so if you guys like figuring out
that kind of stuff you should have a lot
of fun reading for Tatia I'm figuring
out things
yes exactly Karl Carson art got a tease
got a key you got a tease a little bit
you can't just you know let let
everything loose immediately yeah yeah
look at look at the way to her right
does it yeah he's a master tease sternum
artisan master master teats always tease
me yeah but we love it when he teases us
we need it so that's the thing I I liked
the idea of like bye thanks but not not
giving you all of it you know I like
that I like I like the idea of letting
the audience figure things out I don't
want to just be here like this is what
it's all about and I feel like I've done
a relatively decent job to of like tell
you guys what toddy is about without
telling you what toddy is about so if
that's any so that means anything yeah
I've been trying really hard not to give
away details that'll be spoiler if it
another super chat bro so happy for you
got my order and can't wait to read
chapter house video cylinder course the
chapter house video swimming works
obviously it's had to be like postponed
a little bit because there's anything
going on I've been literally moved
across the country and now I'm releasing
Tatia so there's been super busy but
chapter house is coming out I want it to
be my best student video so yeah it is
coming out and it's super something
super exciting about thank you for the
super chat thanks everybody from back in
the campaign the super chats are great
by the best way to support the channel
if you just want to do it to the channel
is their PayPal and there should be a
PayPal link not in the description it's
totally not there but it's like you can
ideas lesson fire at gmail.com is the
PayPal you can find it there but cool
yeah but most importantly that's what
we're on today we're talking about um
let us let's see how many backers have
gotten up to you
it's been like 10 minutes since I've hit
the refresh button
[Music]
clothing you guys could probably tell me
quicker than my internet can load in
honestly hey guys look look here give it
a break though like they are like
throttling me right now because I've
used too much data and then also like
I'm streaming I'm a hot spotting to my
laptop to my tablet and to my TV so it's
like it's doing actually like not bad
for all of the devices that I have
connected to it on like a limited Oh
where's Phil Phil's here Oh Phil what's
up I haven't seen you in a minute buddy
hey dude she's filthy issues guys is the
issues gay man are you watching this
alright cool 161 backers they say yeah
look at this ladies let me actually
disconnect yeah yeah let's get it to 6k
at least you're in their stream guys
don't know how long I'm gonna be
streaming but let's see if we can get to
6k that'd be freaking awesome guys it's
just a few hours okay I can't even like
reiterate in enough I can't believe it
it's so crazy it's absolutely insane
it's absolutely and so I'm just like
really really thankful to like so have
you guys be some sport Phil says lots of
love when thank you so much Phil her to
stop and buy you support the growth of
them and thanks great for putting that
up that is totally that if you just want
to donate to the channel so thanks for
that
yeah great works looks like a cool
IndieGoGo why did my computer just lock
itself randomly did you see that what
what is happening that is guys is a
really bizarre my computer just like
locked itself
it's like mercury in retrograde keeps
doing it okay it's really bizarre
yeah oh my god I didn't click on the
magnifier oh my guys my if you could see
what my computer was doing right now
you'd be like I can't confirm like I
have no idea
someone's there's some witchery afoot
there are some witchery afoot but I've
never seen it I don't know what's going
on okay I can see I'm still streaming as
I can see you guys it's Chad stuff I can
see you guys chest I guess that's all
that matters but my like actual laptop
here is freaking the flip out all right
I think I can actually reset the laptop
without having to like take down the
stream because since I'm since I'm on my
phone so let's go let's do that yeah you
started your stream and then I freaked
it yeah dang computer yeah I don't I
don't know what's going on advise
someone there's there's a there's an
enemy which trying to curse me or
something people are doing rituals to
stop Todd yes
they recognize that she will be their
undoing no amount of magic can stop
Tatia is this the most death in a run
George oh yeah so do it her no have my
little all I do let's talk about it so
yeah so if you go if you remember it
like charm Tron was asleep then you go
check on yeah John was like this really
really crappy 90s TV show about three
witches about three witches basically
and they were like three sister witches
and they fought demons basically that's
not what hottie is about but like this
symbol here this triple goddess symbol
shows up Italia
but I love that show as a kid that show
was great as a kid for me because I was
like cool which is awesome
sweet I like witches I want to [ __ ] I
want to follow these characters and I
was super into it but like there was a
lot of like continuity problem show a
lot of inconsistencies you can tell
there was a lot of rioters no one really
liked kept a consistent normally cared
about it so I always think like I could
tell my own witch story which story
about like riches or whatever I could
make it really super cool and so that's
basically what Tatia is it's my own
witch story so it's not exactly inspired
by a charm but it's loosely but it's
inspired by a lot of things actually can
go through the influences I don't know
if I did that yeah I haven't actually
and everyone's saying it's over 6,000
now we're over 6,000 on IndieGoGo Jesus
Christ Jesus Christ guys let's go to the
influence you guys are just yeah we're
at a hundred and sixty five backers over
six thousand so let's talk about the
influences for Tatia so I have a few of
my influences for this book specifically
listed here obviously I have personally
I've got a lot more literary influences
obviously but these are the specific
ones for Tatia so number one was Neil
Gaiman obviously I talk about Neil
Gaiman earlier I've been a huge fan of
his work and like Sandman and other
books that he's done for a really really
long time yeah I love how he just the
metaphorical symbolic storytelling is is
really awesome to me and then also
Stephen King so still inking is the king
of horror they know the deep the way he
could tap into the primal fears that we
all have is something that I definitely
try to do and recreate in Tatia
so looks like my computer's coming back
on here
so it looks like Jordan Amman Jordan
Martin obviously I couldn't not say
Georgia are mark Verner Martin totally
changed modern fantasy um what I wanted
what I took from george RR martin to
make patio that's basically the way
there's no black and white in georgia
martin's universe there's no life just
straight-up good or you know and it's
really just about the characters and
they exist just kind of like seamlessly
in like a fantasy world and it doesn't
deal in jarring ever over-the-top ever
and that's what I wanted to do with
Katya I don't know there's a low prep
which you can probably predict from like
the art of Tati or just here in the
description of it kind of there is
deadly solo craft stuff going on in
audience better bottom dollar so yeah
that sense of light on ease and just
dark things awaiting my terrors to come
so yeah solo cough is all about things
waiting below the earth there's things
waiting in the stars that are older and
more ancient more terrible you could
ever imagine so yeah that was a I
definitely put some elements of the
Lovecraft stuff in Talia yeah that we
did and so let's get into let's skip one
and then go back so Frank Herbert
obviously with the daughters of couple
the daughters of hatate are heavily
influenced by the baby desert sisterhood
as well as many other groups of
matriarchal women in fiction you know
there's some ice dye in there there's
some women of Avalon in there but yeah
so Frank River but then here's the most
interesting one I think so we get l
frank Baum and Lewis Carroll who wrote
The Wonderful Wizard of Oz and Lewis
Carroll homage to know Alice in
Wonderland so both of those books
Alice's Adventures in Wonderland through
the looking-glass and The Wonderful
Wizard of Oz are about like these young
girls that kind of just stumble into
like a magical realm and slowly and
things are never as they appear and so I
think that's Tatia at a nutshell like it
always starts
like the stories that affected you like
I think in childhood those were the
stories that always stuck with me and
basically Katya is a very very I mean
you can take this with a grain take this
as far as you want it but like it's kind
of like a very very dark version of
something like The Wizard of Oz or
Alison it's not like I'm trying to be
I'm not telling those stories but it has
some of those elements that I was
referring to or short and my computer
has decided to turn my gone after like
locking itself and then doing a dish
check for no reasons but whatever so now
we can get back onto the stream so I can
actually see the chat moving in real
time so yeah guys we are killing this
campaign so far let me actually look at
it right now that I'm getting back set
up and pop out this I don't actually
need the stream to be up on am on mobile
hotspot you can do it load it a few more
seconds what do we get now guys we're at
over 6,000 there's black list universe
and mic mic if you wanna hop on the
stream I will send you the link in just
a second so I'll post it in the in on
Twitter like if you wanted to see it so
just hop in if you want so we can talk
about your cover that you did for Tatia
so Talia is at a hundred sixteen backers
we're at six thousand one hundred and
seventy so we are killing it right now
guys we are killing it let's go to the
IndieGoGo homepage to see what we're
doing
still number two we're still number two
on the front page when you go go around
the front page of IndieGoGo so tell it
like I can't even complain about the
igniter - I mean it's the front page
mini go though let's get some light in
here
she lights up my beautiful face oh just
so let's go to stream yard so I can oh
yeah
sorry Mike I totally forgot you totally
told me victory totally forgot
but thanks for stopping by thanks for
stopping by
yeah yeah my poor internet Mike they're
coming by to fix it tomorrow
god I'd have bitten so hard to like get
internet with like everything that's
been going on just like oh my god move
to new place it's like such a struggle
to be a youtuber and not having an
internet kana blows is Todd iam one now
what do you mean is this book is this
audiobook one this is Tatia book one
that is on presale right now yes that is
what this is but there will be three
books this this is the story of split
into three it's all written it's a
matter of it being interpreted and drawn
at least and then like I said after it's
all done after all three of them I'm
going to put them all together and I'm
gonna do the novelization of it so I was
going through my perks earlier I'll go
through them again for everyone if
anyone's just getting here so we've got
a bunch of perks so we've got the early
bird special which I did talk about
earlier so the early bird special is
like three hot three sayonara cover
copies three metal prints it comes with
also a digital copy tan and audio script
version for 250 which is actually a
really good deal
it's married it's like 25 percent off
that's a good $335 rico it says there
and then it's those people who claim
that one but then we wanted them really
like I said we wanted a really really
low price point for the entry level
stuck right so if you you can get the
story for $10 Evo holy and they can get
a paperback for 15 and then if you want
to like build a all out and be like
super supportive then you can get a sign
over that for 30 and then got some
discounts on the bundle packs and then
you can get like a hardcover for 50 or
sign hardcover for 75 and that more
bundles for boggles abundance
and then of course there were the
original weld in our pages which come
with altars like this if you got the
original if you got a pay it you get to
pick the page you want and then you'd
get all right cover blah
sighing and you get like a paperback
copy digital copy metal print I think
it's there to make sure that there is
actually a little complete I think
there's yes let's see there's a metal
press you get get all that jazz and the
last one it's just like the better
version that the end of the most
expensive tear there's only like ten of
those so I don't expect like that'd be
super crazy but yeah there's only like
yeah you know me laugh so those are my
tears yeah 15 not that I thought so I
wanted I thought he was really
affordable because I see like everyone's
are charging like 25 30 or like their
paperback so I'm just like I don't know
man III know what the printing cost is
and then we got we got that so I don't
want to like nickel and dime everyone I
just want everybody to read it and then
that was basically philosophy we were
pretty much dead set from the beginning
of having like the very low entry price
point and super awesome I'm a super
awesome that everyone is back there's
also a limited amount of these sign
copies as well so if you want to get a
signed copy kinda have to act before we
run out of those and they are selling
and which is great it's great oh it's
cert on sir Oh what's up servants what's
up I dig your Twitter message I'm sorry
I have not had a chance to respond yet
but I will respond as soon as I can it's
for busy as everyone you can probably
tell so I'm not gonna open up the stream
your thing yet because this string nerd
so Bunyan said Bunyan Snipes I just got
a signed copy awesome thanks everyone
like really genuinely thanks everyone
that's supporting it someone says Dave
what are you doing
he's just chillin in the back house
doing Dave things he's doing Dave things
so what we're Sur hunts that I just saw
there you go
What's Up sir hunts thanks for popping
in and thank you bunions snipe or
popping in and getting a signed copy
super awesome be more quiet with the
rapper
let's see sir hug says what's up Lucifer
okay but I'm screaming so yeah we're
doing we're doing real good sir at 62 58
so it's good right Mike doing good right
see that's the thing I mean I was trying
to seize earlier I hadn't know what to
expect with this I had no idea I had no
idea of him I was gonna wanna buy this I
had no idea if like we're gonna sell any
books but it looks like you guys are
super into this and excited about it and
it just means just means the world to me
there really does it means the world
it's like the greatest feeling to have
something that I have written people be
so interested in reading it and I hope
that you guys enjoy it and I hope that
you guys read this one and want to read
the second one and yeah it's it's just
all it's all just very very very very
exciting
Alecia Kingston says of course we want
to buy this you've got skills to keep
writing
thank you so much Alicia for saying so
kind words and there's great area to
posting the link again to the IndieGoGo
campaign which just launched this
morning this morning at around so how
long ago was it at this point not too
long ago five hours going on five hours
ago okay
let's see excellent
someone says is it full color yes it is
full color and actually the covers that
you're seeing up on indiegogo campaign
page right now are actually being
colored by John Francois velia right now
so that is absolutely epic ad John
Francois did all is doing all the colors
in the book and he also did Middle West
recently for image and like I said I was
a fan of him before oh we sold an
original art page we sold an original
art somebody got one I'll have to see
that one but yes it looks like somebody
got one of our original art pages so
with the original art age those are all
of the matthew weld and original pages
and that comes with like a digital copy
of Tatia a sign hardcover top copy a
paperback copy a metal print on digital
audio strip and an original weld and art
page so Wow thanks to the person that
bought the original art like Jesus that
is so thank you so much for supporting
Matthew nice project both of us are
super excited and won one of these days
we'll be streaming on here with Matthew
Weldon we'll get Matthew on it's so
funny I hope he's not embarrassed by me
telling this but like um a message a
message in a messaging him literally
this morning oh yeah we're getting ready
to launch at noon
and he's all like we're launching today
it's just high it's today and I'm like
yeah dude like Matt he kind of lives in
like a timeless dimension which I
understand because I feel like I slip
into a time so I totally get it like
he's an artist so like time when you
don't have a conventional job time does
slowly start to lose me so but you know
it doesn't even matter if you guys like
Matthews just so amazing like Matthew's
like I said earlier it's just like
I could not ask for a better artist and
his style just fit Tatia so perfectly
let me tell you about like when I knew I
went Matthew Walden it's kind of fate
because it's like I was talking to Mike
actually about like who I was gonna get
to like draw the internals of the book
because I know I'm one of them I
actually wanted the covers from the
beginning so he just said Matthew Weldon
and I was like I don't know that isn't
so I looked him up and like one of the
first things I saw was a drawing that
Matthew did of Morpheus from Sandman and
death from Santa and I just looked at it
and I was like yeah this is like him and
it could not have worked out better
because like the amount of passion that
he's putting into every single page it's
just like wow the amount and then on top
of that the amount of passion that
jean-francois ba ba leo is doing with
the color right to have like the
colorist literally message us and be
like I love the story I'm enjoying it so
much I'm having fun coloring this book
like he doesn't have to do that he could
just be like color take the check and
run but he's messaging us telling us how
much he's enjoying it the same with Kane
and I got a message from painting after
we sent him the script and he did the
cover about how much he enjoyed the
story so like I said the fact that we
can have this combination of just like
jaw-dropping art and then what I truly
feel like is a really good story then
it's just amazing so someone said we're
at 7 grand did we hit 7 I can't I can't
might see this tablet will not refresh
the Internet is like the Internet is
like no it's like I'm not you yeah
that's yeah so we're at like 7 grand
almost yeah we're like 69 oh no no we
did it we got over without over
we're over 7 grand if the like button
guys we gotta shut celebrate we are over
7 grand
oh my god guys
guys you're making me so happy we're
doing it we're doing it but this is this
is an indie comic book campaign
we're not like going through like some
big publisher like we're not like having
to go through like a publisher and have
them be like oh we can't do this and we
don't want to do this we're gonna change
this this is this is the way art is
supposed to be this is the way art is
supposed to be produced I feel with like
patrons supporting the things that they
like and it's just it's just amazing
that you guys are willing to do this
over 7 grand on day one
yeah we are we're killing it it's not
even it's with over 7 grand within 5
hours since the campaign it's launched
it's 1 o'clock now and I launched at 8
so 8 9 10 11
oh well yeah just not even 5 hours not
even 5 hours oh god guys yeah but like I
said it's a blessing it's a blessing to
be able to do this yeah yeah so check
the link out that Mike just posted well
than death and dreams yeah so black okay
so cool yeah yeah totally Mike just said
when I have the colors once the covers
are fully colored which they should be
in a few days then we'll have some
samples of the metal prints made so we
can show them off everyone mm-hmm
that'll be I cannot I can't wait you
guys see the colors you can already tell
looking at the cane in art how good it
is but you guys haven't seen the
completed Weldon like I said the Weldon
Art the Weldon cover for this book has
heading higher rapper him and it's got
Silas on there it's got all these on
there it's got a bunch of stuff going
it's got like a tree that she's sitting
on and like wraps around it is beautiful
but welded is such a perfection is that
he's like still working on it so it's
like a guy I don't want to rush him I
want to let him do this thing and it
take as long as he
as absolutely as long as he wanted to do
it just like I totally trust him and his
vision okay man i'ma buy this eventually
but I'm hammering up that's totally fine
Thomas like you can if you can just like
share it on Twitter share it on Facebook
tell everybody don't you know about it
and just share it around anything can't
buy that totally helps every single
little every every little share that you
do helps every little interaction
double-click helps honestly so yeah
we're well over 7 grand now guys we're
at like 7,200 184 backers this campaign
is killing it you guys are killing it
it's you guys it's you guys that's all I
can say it's you guys you guys are you
guys are making this happen for me you
guys are making this happen for me and
Matthew Alton like I said this is our
project this is I did the story he's
bringing the art I tried my best to
write something that meant something I
try my best to write something that was
different something that was scary
something that was entertaining it's not
even I had two characters so yeah we are
number one on comics so we've been
number one on comics for a minute we've
been number one and just creative works
we've actually Mike we hit number one on
IndieGoGo creative works thirty minutes
into the campaign and so now we're like
the someone can go to the front page of
any other one check maybe and see where
we are on the front page at this point I
think it shows you that if you're not
logged for yeah because the last time I
checked we were like number two like
when we like add some I think when I
when I checked the front page like 20
minutes ago 30 minutes ago we were
number two on the front page about to be
number one
so we can beat out whatever that's
stupid I'm sure I'm sure the tech
product is great yeah but if we can be
about that tech product so one thing
we're still number two we can still push
that guy's you can still go we can still
go I think we can do it I think we can
do it I think we
do it yeah the number one spot is
launching soon which is that crazy
what is that crop product but yeah it's
really cool that tada yet a comic book
is like up here with like these million
dollar campaigns these million dollar
tech products and all that guys and
whatnot it's really really really boats
that also make coffee yeah coffee making
your boats or something still second on
the front page
I mean SEC I will take second I was
saying earlier when it was at number six
for a while before I started the stream
and I was saying I hope it good
something like number four so you don't
have to scroll to see it and so now it's
number two so you just click on
IndieGoGo there's Tatia that beautiful
cane and white rendition just looking
absolutely stunning and looking
absolutely horrifying yeah hi guys me
and Dave are married just get over it
but okay so anyway looking at that
beautiful cane and white cover it's just
like it's great so let's talk about the
covers again in case anyone just come in
so we've got three very covers that you
can choose from so you got three very
cover to happen uh they came in white
color and cane and white like like I'm
not it's not hyperbole when I say one of
the best one of the best artists in the
industry
absolutely we've got the Mike Miller
covered beautiful Katya space and then
we've got the Weldon cover and this is
not the finished cover guys this is the
late I am telling you when you guys see
this Weldon cover when you guys see this
welding cover you're going to lose it
this cover is so good and then the
wraparound is so good it's like oh my
god that was really when he sent back to
me early earlier this morning I was like
man you were just like I am so glad to
have you on this project
it's absolutely amazing to have such
great people on man
so we got our campaign well over seven
grand at this point is oh my goodness
streamer is totally for this I'm just
noticing that let me refresh that page
I've got a limited bandwidth let me so I
gotta do funky stuff like disconnect
from the talat real quick and then like
load up the computer and then reconnect
because the connection is so slow oh my
god I'm hoping that we did it fixed
tomorrow okay let me enter the broadcast
studio okay my stream error is fixed
again now I can do stream Giardia things
how does it feel Quinn how does it feel
to just have this coming coming out
right now and have you guys supporting
it it feels I just indescribable
honestly like I said I had no idea how
many people would support this how many
people would want to support this if any
and to have so many people supporting it
it's just we hit number one baby we're
number one
we're number one we're number one on
IndieGoGo I can't see it on the tablet
though remember one on the moon page
don't know oh yeah for me never I don't
I don't I don't trust I don't trust the
MCU batali I'd never trust them with
that no no no no no no she wouldn't fit
in with the rest of them no she wouldn't
number one on IndieGoGo we are number
one on IndieGoGo weed it out to
everybody that you know everyone
everyone in the chat chanting we're
number one type it out in the chat weird
number one we're number one we're number
one
oh my goodness weird number one oh my
god yes you guys did this like what can
I say you guys did this I wrote it
Matthew Alden drew it you guys got it
number one so like this is on my awesome
audience my awesome supporters my
awesome patrons everyone that's
supporting me
we're number one we roll on baby pic
yeah I think any giggles not loading
right because I need the mobile version
of the website I'm just gonna exit out
the string or two she's gonna do
freezing okay here's a lesson in sorcery
this is going down in history
heck yeah baby uh-huh
we're going down in history baby yeah so
so in mobile versions of websites are
just plain annoying I'm like why can't I
see it
that's because it's the mobile version
and it hides it for some reason but yeah
there it is
there she is waiting for it to load in
the picture but yeah Tatia I guess
number one I indigo though Thalia let me
let me let me just Tatia is the number
one campaign
Wow that is that is I don't even know
what to say I just don't I don't I
really really really don't even know
what to say like it's just like so yeah
if you yeah go to the desktop version
yeah the mobile version doesn't show you
have to like click up in your browser
and click on desktop version that's
really dumb but yeah there she is this
no no um get out oh she didn't get out
the first time well she did the first
time yeah yeah I think she knocked over
that thing we're having puppy problems
like the fence in the backyard is not
you look you see Talia you see Todd he
right there number one Wow man guys I
was gonna say something before I got
distracted by the fact that we hit
number one on IndieGoGo like oh my god
I'm so I'm so I'm sorry the stream is
kind of getting bad now because I'm just
like oh I can't even like say anything I
can't even like talk right now I can't
even talk right now
yeah but what I can't what I will say is
I can't wait for you guys to read it I
can't wait for you guys to see it I
can't wait for you guys to hold the book
in your hand the hope to to see the
pages to read the words to absorb it
yeah I mean if we can get to ten
thousand by the end of today late hey
that's gonna be some crazy stuff if that
happens I think it's tough not to
plateau and goals at it and exceeded but
here's the thing maybe we're gonna if we
can hit some stretch goal salute we got
we've got a lot of things for stretch
goals plan a stalk my stretch goals
earlier if enough people back the book
becomes better without becoming more
extensive for the people to buy it'll
still be $15 but then it might be like
just higher quality more pages like more
splash pages and extra art and stuff so
if we can get to sir
stretch goals just I like you guys
sharing it to all of your friends
sharing it everywhere then like we can
all together make the book a better
product than what it already is about to
be so yeah it's barely a few hours and
that's that's what that's what I'm most
excited about is because we just hit
five hours and we're over seven grand
that is like uh this is just we're just
one post okay you'll hear my little
puppy out for a little bit for then
she'll chill go back to sleep out there
the guy who get dog food today yes they
do
so Talia queen of IndieGoGo mom may she
reign yes absolutely
she is queen bow before Tanja what kind
of puppy do I have my puppy is a lab
pitbull mix how can we help get the word
out Quinn well you can help get the word
out by just sharing a link to the
campaign page on just a Facebook Twitter
wherever you do your social media
posting the art with like leaks on
social media Instagram where wherever
just just just spreading it out
everywhere all those all those everyone
is tweeting right now support black
artists because of what's going on hold
them to it
hey now it's the time you know everyone
there are the riots that's been tweeting
on Twitter or like do you support black
artists hey look at my skin I don't I
don't pull the black card very often but
hey it's to sell this book then you know
I'm just kidding but yeah but you know
honestly share it everywhere
do what you can even if you can't afford
to even if you can't afford to back in
yourself just share it everywhere be
awesome what if we live in the 20th
century and don't have any socially here
well then you won't then you're not
gonna get FedEx to ship it to you either
so it's kinda out of luck you can write
letters yeah just yeah that's right a
letter actually it'll be better write a
letter in the past it might bury it and
like set it up so someone like picks it
up like today so it's like Tatia was
always buried
the ground that's what you'll do you can
do that that'll be super cool if you're
in the 20th century but yes thanks
everyone that's supporting I'm sorry I
can't highlight any of you guys's
comments now because I don't have a
stream yard pulled up because my ear is
crappy right now but yeah oh thank you
guys so much for almost that almost at
200 backers we're had a we're at 193
backers already we've had several people
get the early bird special which is
super cool the early bird special so
bright there that comes with metal
prints three metal prints that comes
with a bit three oh the hardcover books
sign becomes with all three covers sign
so you'll get the painting cover the
welding cover and the Miller cover all
three of those books sign as well as all
three of those variants in metal print
as well as a digital copy of Katya and
and Auggie script so yeah that's what's
going on that early bird special but
that one is limited oh yeah I have to
jump on that one if you want that and
then like I said very low price points
for the city little book that's what but
I want to keep driving that home for
everyone
very low price points for the entry
level books because I'm not trying to I
really am NOT trying to like tax anyone
like to me if I can make a profit that'd
be cool
but really what I want to do is get to
look up that's what I wanted to I want
people to read my story and experience
my story I was afraid my computer was
doing that automatic logout thing again
someone said nearly yeah yeah we've hit
yeah we've gone up again we're at 7600
almost 7600 and just over five hours
yeah we need to get seven more backers
seven more backers let's see if we can
get let's see if we can do this before
the end of the stream if we can get
seven if we can get it up to 200 backers
that would be awesome
will the other volumes also have an
IndieGoGo launch that is the plan right
now but if something else goes
differently then maybe it'll be
somewhere else but yeah yeah let's um
that is the plan
and then eventually this this will be on
Amazon initially Tatia so if you do miss
the campaign in several months probably
like closer to like ten months nine
months this will be on Amazon right so
if you don't if you miss out on the
campaign year you can get the book on
Amazon and the property it'll probably
be a little bit more expensive on Amazon
we'll probably have to move it up from
15 for like 25 or something on Amazon
for the curb right but yeah so the
campaign you want to get like the low
price here daddy awesome gotta act on it
we got up to 194 we got six more six
more let's get the two hundred backers
come on guys we can do it we can do it
see I feel like I think the digital copy
for $10 is very compelling to like if
you just want to get the store and it's
like let me check out Quinn story
because I'd like him and I want to
support him in any way I can
or let me check out Quinn story because
I want to see it and see if it sucks or
whatever it's only $10 so it's like you
can totally do that and doesn't the
option ship so when the when the book is
done and everything is colored and
everything is totally totally finished
um the digital copies will go out first
so if you buy one if you buy any of
these paperback books or any other
hardcovers you can add a digital copy
when you check out so the digital copy
will come out first because we have to
ship the physical copies obviously and
print them and all that stuff so the
digital copies are going to go out first
so the people that got the digital copy
will be able to read Tatia and you know
do all that stuff so that's really cool
let's see
so right now pages are where we got five
away five away from 200
purposes I prefer the physical copy to
be honest me as well I do as well I
always prefer like holding a comic with
my hand like I actually like omnibuses
and absolute volumes like the really
I like oversized to graphic novel
volumes which if we can do that for
Tatia eventually that'd be great and
that could be like a stretch goal or
something in the future that'd be
awesome
like a big oversized book I love those
because like you just open it up and
it's like you're transported into the
world immediately it's freaking sweet
it's absolutely freaking sleep mm-hmm so
physical copy you can always give to
kids or to ladies or to comic shops or
use bookstores
yeah that's true that is true see I I
don't buy a lot of ebooks but I do use
comixology which is like a really
awesome service that's like five bucks a
month they let you like try a bunch of
like let's say if there's like a new
there's like a trade paperback that I'm
looking at on Amazon and I'm super
interested in it go to comixology they
probably have that first volume for free
to read so you can just check it out
real quick and so that's basically what
I use this tablet or like where you
check out comics and stuff so let's
check out the page again we have jumped
we jumped up to one away from 200 we're
one away from 200 warmer to go who's
gonna be who's a gone OB and we're at
almost 7800 oh my goodness oh my god ray
great you are such a trip she said I
know I was just kidding oh my goodness
great thanks great for your support we
hit weren't too ordered into I didn't
get to get you to the 200 but yeah we're
at 202 that's even better though when my
playing about well you
killing this 203 Oh guys Lauren's
coroner says if Quinn gets to 10 grand
I'm gonna put my kilt on and dance I I
mean that'd be cool to see that would be
cool to see Lauren for sure
the true Scottish comes out winters mill
says you're my favorite Channel clan
thank you so much thank you so much for
watching the channel and enjoying it
how is that possible my pledge number is
2 to 2 I have no idea I don't even know
how that spot maybe it's like some flag
in the thing or something
yeah we're still going we're still going
we see 2 cent we hit 207 we're over 8
we're over 8,000 we're well over 8,000
we just want well over 8,000 someone got
another one of the early bird specials
which like I said is a super good deal
yeah those metal prints are going to
look you know like comics eyes they're
gonna look fantastic once we get those
completely done and those covers are all
going to be colored and completely done
and that Matthew Weldon one like I said
we're revealing the finished full
Matthew Weldon cover later today we're
gonna reveal like the bath it's got that
wrap around it's got that front so we're
gonna reveal all of that later today
milady lady for you crypto X listen
milady tip in the fedora
I don't usually timid or maybe that's
something I just start doing it like
cringy endure today this is technically
not a fedora
but like see this here's to think let me
let me reveal the mystery of this hat
right I have no idea what this hat is I
don't even care like people have very
strong reactions to this hat they're
like I hate fedoras and then some people
are like it's just so and so and I'm
like to me it's just a hat that I won't
wear because I'm like wait looks sad but
whatever but I'll tip it for you yeah
like you guys are the bomb this is great
you're right they are they are absolute
let me change my computer settings so
it's
keep turning the screen off while I'm
streaming while you're doing this to
change power settings windows what you
gotta be so rude
[Music]
how do you change it on windows so it
doesn't turn off after late choose when
to put the display to sleep no I don't
want the display to go to sleep you
douche
Save Changes imbecile dumb windows stop
trying to ruin my stream windows alright
yeah let's see what's going on the chat
again just support your campaign thank
you so much Catherine Morgan oh so you
got signed copy I'm so I'm so excited
I'm so excited that you supported the
campaign I'm so excited for all of you
supporting the campaign it's like ah so
I guess it I just get stumbled up on my
words because I'm just like wordless so
we're at 2:10 backers now like are we
going to get to 10,000 by the end of
this stream like that's like it didn't
reach now we're at like nearly 8500 like
if you guys can just like keep backing
cuz every time any time that you back
what's happening is that it's pushing me
up in IndieGoGo x' algorithm basically
and so more people who are seeing it and
that's the same with you guys sharing it
the more and more you share the more it
pushes it up I'm not a crack I'm not
gonna track you guys my me I am cried on
the stream before you can't get if I hit
10,000 maybe that'd be awesome it is a
bit overwhelming I might cry after the
stream honestly I might crafter the
street because it is a little bit over
well Marilyn Barry backing definitely
makes me crash it makes me emotional
it's in it is a very just it's very
surreal and it's a very wonderful
emotional experience putting this out
here and having it
accepting to having people like it and
like I said on one of these streams
probably not today because Matthews
working hard on his cover and whatnot
finishing that up for a day but one of
these trains will get Matthew on here
and we can have a chat with me and
Matthew because like I said the passion
that he has for the project and that yes
for his work in his craft is just one of
the things that catapulted just it just
makes it that much better you know what
I mean the fact that he's willing to put
his all into it the society have both
yours and the artists signature right
now just to mine but we'll have to
figure out something it might officially
just mine but by the time that we launch
we might end up with Matthews signature
as well but officially right now just
mine so that's all that we actually
fully had their fight cuz Matthews in
Texas I'm in California so it's like he
said he's gotta sign his original pages
but like if we didn't we'll see what we
can do with it we'll see what we can do
and I am just currently logging in to my
YouTube so that on this tablet vlog that
for some reason so that I can see the
chat from the tablet alright done I
can't wait for my sign in paperback
thank you so much thank you so much for
getting a signed paperback thanks for
being so supportive like everyone like
really really truly it's so impressive I
mean it's just it's so it's it's it's I
can't I'm without words alert CBD 19 and
Matt Koval stacked for the dunes stuff
what's going on
those are Matt Coco has the cool doomed
series doesn't Lee doesn't he where we
talking about Karl car starts when gonna
be nerd famous
the master of dueling as a nerd famous
haha your link is up on binge mode
Facebook page already lots interest
really that's awesome I'll go check that
out and just I'll check that out now
actually and see what's going on you
guys will let me know like I said guys
any places you can think to share this
any like group that would be interested
in like Facebook um anyone that you know
that's interested in comics like friends
shared on Twitter if you back it show
that you backed it on Twitter if you
didn't if you can't back it right now
just share it on Twitter yeah sorry guys
I'm Titan stuff I cannot type every chat
talk at the same time it's a flaw of
mine I just cannot do it so we are we
are number one on IndieGoGo like I keep
looking at that like wondering if it's
like this is how did that even happen
how that happen that is that's I didn't
do that I impressed the remote that was
someone's witchcraft
witchcraft was telling that someone is
like working they were just turns TV off
right now like the same way my computer
just turned off like that just popped up
like there are dark forces at work that
are trying to destroy my tiny lunch
I don't know what that was Jane Smith
says I backed for hardcover so excited
thank you so much days that I'm sharing
it on post geek singularity Facebook
right now thank you so much buying a
snipe like I said sure it everywhere
that you possibly can getting the word
out is like the most important thing
right now and you guys are just like
tremendously important um the thing
about crowdfunding is that that it's
exactly what it sounds like crowdfunding
so it's like we have to get it out there
we have to talk about it we got to
mention it we got to do straight
gotta do the sharing we got to make it
happen and we are making it happen it
looks like I have put my kilt on says
Lauren's corner let's do ten K so it
says D and D overtook the computer here
I'm not sure how to the eto delayed the
quick way okay that should look that
back up whatever it'll take it
sweetheart all right let's see
yes thanks great for sharing the link
once more Catherine Morgan says love
your voice definitely do an audiobook -
there is an audio script that is
available as an add-on if you if you get
it's not on the front page but once you
get to checkout you can see at the
bottom and there is an audio script with
me narrating that will be available the
entire script which that will probably
be little crap that will be available as
soon as set of all of the parts probably
on your script the audio script and then
the e-book and then of course we'll get
the books the actual physical books all
shipped to everyone
everything books at the crack 1996 it's
great movie rain will be the crap is I
watched a lot of which things growing up
I've watched a lot of which things in
general
III consume a lot of which me yeah it's
always been something that I've been
that I've found really compelling the
idea they had like magical woman and I
can expect things from afar it's very
very scary or at least it can be a lot
of times it can a lot of times it's
silly a lot of times with magic and
witches when it's in the hands of like
someone that doesn't really like care or
understand that you have to like set
limits for like magic and what witches
or wizards
it's over the top like my time trouble
anytime like to introduce like magical
time travel it's almost good sleep if
you can just cast a spell this it just
turns into just atcha
yeah turn to the second thing it's the
sounds
you
can you hear me now can you hear me now
where's the mic time for some classic
mic shuffling and plugging in of the new
life yes I don't think my audio is gonna
be synced up with my lips anymore
because of this but it's okay we are
streaming off of a phone here we are
streaming off of a phone from mobile hot
cast browsing off of oh and yeah that's
what's going on so let me just cam mic
audio mic is Samsung okay
is it synced up with my lips the sink is
fine is it really well didn't that's
excellent okay so now see I should have
figured that out earlier that's actually
a much better way to get the audio
sounding good which is like to run the
audio from the computer but have the
video from the phone yeah so now it's
even better than it was before see it
all works out we just had to like lose
the audio for a while and go robot it
see these these Tatia hatin witches
can't can't stop us with their with
their hack job spells you know and
they're no match no match we're almost
at 85 we need five dollars someone if
someone goat gets a digital copy right
now we'll be at eight will be over 8500
we only need five bucks to get over 8500
right now someone please get a digital
copy or paperback copy for 15 if you
want or sign them back for 30 if you
want just kids yeah someone go back so I
go back
we're almost there were almost over 85
and of course my Internet's going slow
again but it's ok it's ok well I think
book if you want to send me $5 PayPal
link ideas of Ice and Fire have PayPal
there you go
taro says frozen whirlpool indeed ok
toddy uh the purple bookworm says I got
a sign paperback copy thank you so much
and thanks everyone that is aborted
thanks everyone man oh man we need we
need five dollars we need five dollars
we need someone with some Savior to come
in until we can get to 85 while we're
doing so well we're at eight hundred and
fifty percent of our flexible goal but
we crossed it we crossed it and we
crossed it like we crossed it baby we
crossed it it looks like I'm getting
everything you see yeah you guys just
keep me updated with like where we're at
in the chat because like I'm always
behind because of the really messed up
internet situation right now but yeah
sweet someone says there's a delay on
the campaign page well thank you so much
purple bookworm for backing and thinks
everyone that's back um can we go back
to our our order and add the audio
option I think there's probably an
option to edit it if not then you might
be able to like cancel and read back I'm
Mike milk Mike you might know this
because you've done campaigns can they
go back and like edit their things and
add like some add-ons that weren't there
like if they've already ordered it can
they go add-on add-ons cuz I don't know
oh there you go
Mike just said it you've got a which is
what I thought you've got if you if you
want to go back and add on add on you
have to
you probably got a refund and then
repurchase okay cool
yeah but the audio version is available
it's not on the front page but it's
available once you want you're in the
checkout and you've selected any one of
the tiers then you can add on an
audiobook mm-hmm yeah Wraith ooh little
says oh I wonder out outside for a few
minutes come back and you're 1,500
higher while awesome I know I can't even
believe it I don't yeah I mean it's it's
you guys is it's you guys a support
that's what's that's what it is it's you
guys
being willing to support the campaign
being willing to back campaign and help
us out help us get this made help us get
this made breakthrough says that is the
power of Quinn that is the power of
toddy uh that is the power of toddy out
let me move my camera over I'm not
really good frame frame now there we go
so we are it's so funny man there's been
a lot of roadblocks I've been moving and
a lot it's been super hectic and I don't
have internet but I gotta launch this
campaign
it's like Mike said to me yesterday like
how are you not a lobster campaign if
you don't have look good Internet and I
was like I can like do all this
complicated stuff to kind of like make
it kind of work and I it's actually this
stream is actually going pretty freakin
good I will say the stream is fun really
good it we've cut out a couple times but
for the most part it's been really good
yeah and Matthew Wilden is a super fast
artist with more like young wilderness
so fast that's that's why that's
generally something I noticed working
with Matthew Alden when he when he says
I'm gonna have this art he has it so
quickly
it's just like wow wow so yeah thanks
everyone for backing so far I have
that's pulled up again so I should go
through all the tiers at least another
time for anyone that might have been
just joining had to go check on the
puppy real quick so for anyone that
might just be joining I'll go through
all of my tears once again I haven't
refreshed this page in a while but yeah
early bird special that's an early bird
thing it comes with three hard covers
signed three metal prints all the
variants signed digital copy and then an
audio copy and there's a digital copy
which is the first actual tier $10 epic
super affordable $15 paperback the image
isn't loading it for some reason but a
sign paperback copy 30 bucks
all three hard covers at a discount and
then the hardcover copy of Tatia 450 and
then of course to sign hardcover 475
some more bundles and then of course the
original art which somebody is actually
already bought an original art page I
mean that comes with like the hardcover
paperback metal prints digital ebook all
that jazz and the same with the be in
the book comes with the be in the book
comes with two hard covers so it comes
with a sign hardcover and then a regular
hardcopy so you can get like two covers
if you want two different covers one
sign one not and then it comes with a
metal print digital copy audio script
and an art page and you get to be drawn
into the book so that's for like that's
for like the the top somebody that wants
to super go crazy with a campaign and
get in the book yeah
we're dogs make a cameo who be stretch
go maybe maybe that's interesting I
didn't so much think about that but that
would be cool put my puppies in there
have them pop up in the story for a
little bit
someone says chilling Adventures of
Sabrina I have that book I have that
books chilling at metres of Sabrina that
is by Acacio of guire what's his name
I can't Roberto I think LoCascio choir I
think his name is and I think he's
actually working on the show too and
then he's um
the weather the graphic novel chilling
mr. Sabrina is so good the art is
terrifying the story lights such a dark
twist on Sabrina I'm like oh my god like
have you seen the show you think all the
show is kind of dark but it's kind of
like hokey a little bit the graphic
novel is just straight-up dark the
graphic novel is not like letting yeah
it's just giving it to you dark what's
the greatest graphic novel you've ever
read and this point in my life I'm
really Sandman I love Sandman so over
Turin particular salmon overture I love
salmon Overture so much I mean that
might just be because I'm like obsessed
with Gaiman right now Neil Gaiman but
yeah salmon overture is legit I
recommend it to anyone
oh yeah Alan Alan Moore Watchmen is also
classic really good one yeah so we're
gonna have to end the stream pretty soon
here now so I will be streaming probably
tomorrow and if not tomorrow then the
day after tomorrow
we're only streaming a lot now that
Tatia is launched i'll Futaba arthur c
clarke yes i have i've read some of his
work at least some aware of him now what
did he do I always forget what he did is
that the ohm is that androids do address
electric sheep because if that's him
then yes but yeah guys I just want to
say thanks everyone that has backed
Tatia share it share it share it share
it we're at eight six six zero oh my god
continue sharing continue joining me
for the streams we're still number we're
number one on IndieGoGo right now we're
the number one campaign of any kind on
IndieGoGo which is just breathtaking and
that's all because of you guys it's all
because you guys sharing that's all
because of you guys backing it's all
because of you guys just being just like
tremendously supportive with this
project and I can't even begin to thank
everyone that has supported in any way
and especially the people that have
backed for helping and for wanting to
see this project come to fruition and
for helping us see it get made
Matthew Weldon I actually speak for both
of us when we just said we're so so
grateful that you guys are helping us
fund this campaign and like I said share
share share share the links thanks
Lauren for joining thanks great area for
being so supportive being a great mod
who else ray through Lou thanks a you
pack mule and also there you go cuz I'm
always seeing you here you've been on
you've been on this you've been up in my
strands for like months and months and
months and months so there you go thanks
everyone
like I said we're putting out this
independent comic we're not going
through like some big company we're not
going through some big publishing
company we're doing this ourselves so
it's like just really important that you
guys share it and do whatever you can to
support it and we're so thankful and
we're so grateful and we're really
really appreciated Tavia exordium so
Tatia i think i did i say this at the
beginning I think I started to say this
at the beginning
but didn't so Tatia exordium just means
Tatia the beginning Tatia the
commencement that's a start but exordium
is a really epic and kind of witchy way
of saying that I thought so Tatia
exordium available for presale now and
IndieGoGo get it there's all sorts of
discounts no and greatly appreciate it
guys I'm gonna run still gotta eat you
gotta feed the doggies thanks everyone
we're gonna get out of here now and
peace thank you for backing the campaign
thank you for backing she drives me
crazy
tiny it drives me crazy baby baby
Tonia Tonia Tonia Tonia Tonia Tonia you
should back tell you on IndieGoGo I love
you guys peace